[Applaudissements]
grâce à ses très peu n'a tout le monde
qui écoutent du français finalement
c'est mon album qui se vend ailleurs en
europe grâce à cette petite phrase en
anglais
je pense que au contraire c c'est une
victoire pour la francophonie en compte
des contraintes du smic
j'ai décroché l'affût à vous avez pas
c'est un truc là yanhel sonne
qu'est ce que ça veut dire tant les
faudrait peut-être un peu répété parce
qu'à faire du
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que les deux chansons vous
avez diffusé sont les seuls deux que
j'ai alors c'est quoi le dit c'est quoi
celui qui me rend celle qui me rend fort
je voudrais seulement celui dangereuse 1
je te chercherait comme la mélodie de ma
chanson c'est très poétique
[Applaudissements]